hey guys it is Monday and this story
wasn't quite big enough to make the cut
today but I wanted to let you guys know
that the sims 4 is finally getting
customizable dogs and cats but the four
of you who play the sims and watch the
show I hope you appreciate that
for everyone else here's today's news
tonight marks the 10-year anniversary of
the Bioshock series and as someone who
wears more than one frame 2 Bioshock
print on their wall in their bedroom I'm
gonna have a really hard time holding on
to my money about this one
2k have revealed a 200 dollar Bioshock
collector's edition and if you'd kindly
stay tuned here's the details on that
the collector's edition is available for
those of you in the US and it includes
an 11 inch statue featuring a big Daddy
and little sister if you aren't quite
hooked yet apparently said statue also
features lights a motorized drill and
audio clips of both characters you also
get a numbered certificate of
authenticity and a physical copy of
Bioshock the collection of the ps4 or
Xbox one the collection includes
Bioshock and Bioshock 2 but without
multiplayer as well as a port of the PC
version of BioShock Infinite it's - out
on November 14th and will only be
available at Game Stop and through the
2k store pre-orders alive if this sounds
like something you absolutely want to
get right now if that last story didn't
make you feel old enough Age of Empires
bulwa has finally been announced and
it's the first entry in the main line
series in 12 years 12 years ago I was on
my gap year which is in between high
school and getting a real job or going
to university where you just kind of
sleep in your parents house and play
Metal Gear Solid 3 every day until you
get all the cutscenes anyway if you're
feeling like you didn't really need to
know where I was 12 years ago I'll be
frank with you I'm trying to pad out
this story because at this stage we
don't really know anything the game is
arriving from Dawn of War and Company of
Heroes studio relic and there's a vague
cinematic trailer out that you're more
than welcome to scan for clues one thing
is for sure their age of empires 4 will
no doubt start consuming my evenings and
weekends just like it did when I was a
kid I cannot wait so I can't tell you
when that one's arriving yet but what I
can tell you is that Age of Empires
definitive edition the remaster of the
first game in the series is arriving on
October 19th exactly 20 years after the
original release
there are also definitive editions of
Age of Empires 2 and 3 in the works
PC friends are having a really good day
today because not only has there been a
new Age of Empires announced Final
Fantasy 15 is coming to PC a new trailer
revealed that epic void and adventure
2016 will arrive on PC in early 2018 the
video came from and in video
presentation so understandably it treats
you to the high-definition sights of
wild beasts far reaching landscape
and Cindy's hat like you've never seen
before the PC version is set to include
4k textures high quality ambient
occlusion and advanced hair simulation I
don't know what that is but I definitely
want to get some because I'm going bald
it's too early to say whether the PC
Edition will include the games upcoming
multiplayer comrades expansion but stay
tuned to game spot and we'll make sure
you know as soon as we do that is
everything we've got for you today do
let us know what you thought of today's
stories down in that comment section and
we will see you tomorrow 12 years ago I
was on my gap year which is when you
finish high school and don't really want
to do anything so you just kind of sleep
in your parents bedroom sleep in your
parents bedroom whoops whoops a little
bit too real that 12 years ago